what is the least common multiple
abbreviated as lcm
of 15 6 and 10. so the least common
multiple is exactly what the word is
saying it's the least common multiple of
these numbers and i know that probably
didn't help you much but let's actually
work through this problem so to do that
let's just think about the different
multiples of 15 6 and 10 and then find
the smallest multiple the least multiple
they have in common so let's find the
multiples of 15 so you have 1 times 15
is 15. 2 times 15 is 30. then if you add
15 again you get 45 you add 15 again you
get 60. you add 15 again you get you get
75 you add 15 again you get 90. you had
15 again you get 105.
and if we if still none of these are
common multiples with these guys over
here then we might have to go further
but i'll stop there for now so that's
that's the multiples of 15 up through
105. obviously we can we can keep going
from there we can keep going from there
now let's do the multiples of six
let's do the multiples of six one times
six is six two times six is twelve three
times six is eighteen four times six is
twenty four
five times six is thirty six times six
is thirty six
seven times six is forty 8 times 6 is 48
9 times 6 is 54 10 times 6 is 60. 60
already looks interesting because it is
a it is a common multiple of both 15
and 60. although we have two of them
over here we have a 30 and we have a 30
we have a 60 and a 60 so the smallest
common multiple so if we only cared
about the least common multiple of 15
and 6 we would say it's 30. so let me
write this down as a kind of
intermediate the lcm
of 15
and 6 so the least common multiple the
smallest multiple that they have in
common we see over here 15 times 2 is 30
and 6 times 5 is 30. so this is
definitely a common multiple and it's
the smallest of all of their common
multiple 60 is also a common multiple
but it's a bigger one this is the least
common multiple so this is 30. we
haven't thought about the 10 yet so
let's bring the 10 in there and i think
you already see where this is going
let's do the multiples of 10. they're 10
20 30
40. well we already went far enough
because we already got to 30 and 30 is a
common multiple 30 is a common multiple
of 15 and 6 and it's the smallest common
multiple of all of them so it's actually
the fact that the lcm of 15
6 and 10 is equal to 30.
now this is one way to find the least
common multiple literally just fine look
at the multiples of each of the number
and then see what the smallest multiple
they have is in common another way to do
that is to look at the prime
factorization of each of these numbers
and the the least common multiple is the
number that has all of the elements of
the prime factorizations of these and
nothing else so let me show you what i
mean by that
so you could do it this way or you could
say 15 is the same thing as 3 times 5
and that's it that's its prime
factorization 15 is 3 times 5. both 3
and 5 are prime
we can say that 6 is the same thing as 2
times 3 that's it that's its prime
factorization both 2 and 3 are prime
and then we can say that
we can say that 10 is the same thing as
2 times 5. that's it both 2 and 5 are
prime so we're done factoring it and so
the least common multiple
the least common multiple of 15
6 and 10 just needs to have all of these
prime factors and what i mean to be
clear is is in order to be divisible by
50 it has to have at least one and one
three and one five in its prime
factorization so it has to have at least
one 3 and at least one 5 by having a 3
times 5 and its prime factorization that
ensures that this number is divisible by
15. to be divisible by 6 it has to have
at least 1 2 and 1 three so it has to
have at least one two and we already
have a three over here so that's all we
want we just need one three so one two
and one three this two times three
ensures that we are divisible by six
and let me make it clear this right here
is the 15. and then to make sure that
we're divisible by 10 we have to have at
least one two and one five we have to
have at least one two and one five
these two over here make sure that we
are divisible by 10. and so we have all
of them this 2 times 3 times 5 has all
of the prime factors of either 10 6 or
15. so it is the least common multiple
and so if you multiply this out you will
get 2 times 3 is 6 6 times 5 is 30. so
either way hopefully both of these kind
of resonate with you and you see why
they make sense this second way is a
little bit is a little bit
better if you're trying to do it for
kind of really complex numbers numbers
where you might have to be multiplying
it for a long time multiple well either
way
both of these are kind of valid ways of
finding the least common multiple